javascript includes many different
syntaxes and techniques to accomplish
the same goals just thinking about what
we learned about objects alone there are
at least three different ways of
defining objects literal dot and bracket
notation when you start debugging other
people's code you're gonna have to wade
through almost two decades of different
syntaxes and techniques layered one on
top of the other you know what this
sounds like a great quiz to me this
course isn't long enough to introduce
everybody to all of the nuances of
JavaScript in fact you can spend more
than a hundred hours in a javascript
class without getting a complete picture
of the language yeah I think I see where
you're going with this let's give
students a piece of JavaScript with some
syntax they haven't yet encountered and
see if they can figure it out this piece
of code should look familiar
you saw something similar a few
exercises ago when you're tracking click
locations on a website there's this
weird syntax here with function location
console dot log et cetera what is going
on here what is document click taking as
a parameter do some research
try testing it out in dev tools and put
your thoughts right here